In high school,
the student interested in taking
apart and rebuilding machines,
approached the CEO of Hewlett Packard
and asked for some parts to help him
complete a class project.
Duly impressed the CEO,
made arrangements for the student to
get the parts and two years later he was
probably thrilled to be able to
say that he took the time to do so.
Because of that confidence.
Students,
you also the parts.
Well,
that was Steve Jobs,
a man who would go on to become the
CEO of apple computers and a preeminent
figure in the tech industry.
Steve jobs was born to two
unmarried graduates in 1955.
Curiously,
this is just nine months before
Microsoft founder Bill Gates.
His parents gave him up
for adoption and jobs,
was 30 years old in well in the midst of
Tech Start and before he learned about
his birth parents symptoms growing up,
the only family he knew
was his adoptive parents.
A couple of from mountain view,
California who fostered his interest in
taking apart and rebuilding machines.
His father pulled jobs,
was a machinist.
He taught jobs about electronics through
now the age working in the family
garage.
The team spent hours tinkering on
projects during those work sessions,
in the carriage jobs.
His father taught him a lesson that has
made its way into apple's products of
all shapes and sizes.
Don't sacrifice any part of the design,
no matter where it is on the product.
Jobs later.
Describe this saying,
when you're a carpenter making
a beautiful chest of drawers,
you're not going to use a
piece of plywood on the back,
even though faces the wall
and nobody will ever see it.
You know it's there,
so you're going to use a beautiful piece
of wood on the back for you to sleep
well at night.
The aesthetic,
the quality has to be
carried all the way through.
The job's showed an early
interest in mechanics and design.
He did not show early promise in school
his mother had taught him to read as a
toddler,
but he was bored in school and often
goofed off a habit that frustrated one
teacher to the point of
bribing him to behave.
This teacher saw potential in a young
jobs and jobs later credited Mrs Hill with
being one of the saints of his life jobs,
so excels in that fourth
grade class with Mrs Hill.
She skipped him over the fifth grade,
entirely anti headed straight
for the middle school.
This jump ahead though,
it was pretty tough for him.
Initially he was bullied and
he became a bit of a loan out.
Indeed,
he disliked middle school so much that
he told his parents that if he couldn't
switch schools,
he would just stop going to
school altogether in order
to keep jobs in school.
The family moved from mountain view to
last Alsace and jobs that settled into
the COUPA Tino school district.
It was here.
The team met and befriended Bill
Fernandez and other students interested in
Electronics Fernandez.
Well,
he later played a critical role in the
creation of apple computers when he
introduced jobs to his neighbor,
another electronics aficionados,
and Bob,
somebody might've heard of
his name was Steve Wozniak.
Yeah,
and we've actually got more
on him on surprisingly.
You get a minute?
No,
by the time he entered high school.
Well,
jobs he was already working at Hewlett
Packard were to cold call to the CEO job
offer,
but while he was in high school,
his interests well,
they began to diversify a desk.
Jobs discovered a love for the
classics and Literature in general,
Dylan Thomas and Shakespeare,
well,
his particular favorites during his senior
year jobs was so excelling in English
that he was able to take
classes at Stanford.
When it came time to attend those jobs,
opted to attend state and Oregon,
but well that didn't
really last very long.
After only one semester jobs.
His previous versions,
he formal education reared
its head and he dropped out.
He continued dropping in on
classes that interested in,
but he wasn't adding any credits
and he wasn't paying for anything.
Interestingly,
one of these classes that he dropped
into when a greatly affected his future,
this is something that he actually
explained in his famous 2005 Stanford
commencement address something by the way,
which is well worth watching.
If I had never dropped in on that
single calligraphy course in college,
the Mac would have never had multiple
type faces or proportionately space fonts.
It's like being a college dropout.
Jobs was able to secure a job
with Atari computers in 1974.
He works as a tack assisting the engineers
who were doing the heavy duty coding
work,
jobs,
dead and tablet,
lots of money at the time,
and he was trying to scrape funds together
to travel to India to study eastern
religion.
Clearly,
here's interesting things
outside of technology,
but it stuck around the of Atari.
Neil bushnell years later said he thought
jobs might've been saving money by
actually living in the office.
I'm not sure about this,
but I think Steve was
actually living there,
so people used to complain
that he didn't smell that well.
I'd come in on the
weekends and it'd be there.
I'd come in late at night and to be
there at the time as it's already also
marked a key points in the friendship
between jobs and his old friend.
Steve wasn't the AG jobs,
was assigned to design a
circuit board for the video.
Game breakouts until you approached,
wasn't act to help because Atari was
offering a bonus if it could be designed
using fewer chips.
Jobs also needed.
The project's completed
as in only four days.
What jobs didn't tell it was New York
was the detory had offered jobs in large
bonus for using fewer chips,
a bonus jobs received and capturing
himself even though wasn't he acted the
majority of the work.
When wasn't he?
I found out about this
like 10 years later.
He's reported to have cried,
but it wasn't a.
He didn't know of.
Jobs is deceased at the time of the teeth.
They consider you to experimenting
with technology together,
but there was a point where they're
tinkering was put on hold because jobs is
living in the office and finally
saved enough money to travel to India.
He went to India in search of spiritual
enlightenment is something that was
rather than the fashion in
the sixties and seventies.
He did this trip on an
incredibly tight budgets.
He slept on the street.
He sweated on crowded buses
and he ate the bad minimum.
He always seems to be
some pretty sketchy food,
reportedly getting dysentery
and losing 40 pounds.
During this time.
He was also meditating and
learning about Zen Buddhism.
He wanted to go to Tibet,
but it's after it's
traveler's checks were stolen.
He decided to head back
home to the united.
When he got back home,
he continued meditation as well as another
habit had picked up that would be the
use of psychedelic drugs jobs.
He was a big fan of Lsd,
drug trade in college,
and would credit with expanding his
creativity and vision of the world.
Taking lsd was a profound experience.
One of the most important
things in my life.
LSD shows you.
There's another side to the coin and
you can't remember it when it wears off,
but you know it.
It reinforced my sense
of what was important.
Creating great things
instead of making money,
putting things back into the stream of
history and of human consciousness as
much as I could.
Back in the United States jobs had no
money and lived in his parent's tool shed
that he had converted into a bedroom.
He wasn't yet continued to work on
computers with jobs convincing Wazniak
there's at least one of the
early products were sellable,
wasn't market built.
A product known as a blue box that could
mimic the tones of a telephone system
and essentially trick iphone into
making a free long distance call with
technology today,
we didn't really think twice about
calling someone on the other side of the
planet,
but in the 19 seventies,
this was a big deal.
Now,
as you might've guessed,
yes,
these blue boxes were totally illegal,
but they did still sell well.
Yeah,
Steve Jobs,
his first business was absolutely selling
illegal devices that allowed you to
make long distance phone calls for free.
Now,
the next brain child,
that wasn't the cats,
well,
it was much more legitimate.
It was a product that
would become the apple one.
In 1976 jobs suggested selling it and
he and wasn't officially started apple
computers.
The company was first granted out of jobs,
his parents garage,
and most of their customers,
they will hobbyists well enough,
computer hobbyists sweat,
laying out money for the apple
one that jobs and Wozniak,
well,
they had cash in their pockets.
Jobs began searching for
investors and wasn't he?
He kept designing in 1977,
which was just one year
after the company launched,
they put out a new version of their
computer called the apple two.
This time there's had color graphics and
was much more user friendly allowing it
to be used outside of
just the hobbyist market.
They sold $3,000,000 of the apple
two in their first year alone,
but this figure,
it was about to become dwarfed.
Two years later they had sold $200,
million dollars worth,
but again,
this seemingly huge number
was about to be dwarfed.
Yet again in 1988,
only four years after that
launch jobs in wasn't the act.
They went public.
By the end of Apple's first
day of public trading,
the company was worth an astounding one.
Point $2,000,000,000.
Steve Jobs was only 25 years old
during the nascent years at apple jobs
was dealing with much personal turmoil.
His long time on again off again,
girlfriend Sam Brennan had moved in
with him and while she got pregnant,
us was by all accounts not
really thrilled about news,
he lays,
started Brennan.
I never wanted to ask
that you guys an abortion.
I just didn't want to do that.
Brendan had been offered a job at apple,
but given jobs his
reaction to her pregnancy,
she did not want to take it.
She left him and that house and began
working as a cleaner despite asking for
support from jobs.
He did not provide any support.
Forest Charles,
until a paternity tests confirmed
that he wants the father even then,
despite his company being
worth over a billion dollars,
he was only required to provide
$500 a month in child support.
Just like these are problems,
Lisa and jobs eventually reconciles and
Lisa or even lived with jobs during your
high school years.
She then attended Harvard and today
she works as a writer in New York City,
though it's again,
yes to admit it.
Jobs actually named one of apple's
early products after his daughter,
but at least it can be used it.
It wasn't as successful as the
apple two had been this failure.
It was followed by another,
the apple three,
which again failed to live up to
expectations and it's not just the jobs as
expectations,
but everyone's.
Despite apple being jobs,
his company,
the fact that it was public meant that
the apple board had the power to oust him
as CEO.
Well,
we did just actually in 1983,
they didn't really fire him.
They just sent him to Siberia.
Not Literally Siberia of course,
but the office he went to was referred
to you with Siberia because it was so out
of the way that it was basically exile.
Now,
most apple employees,
they were probably pleased to see him go.
He was notoriously difficult to deal with
and to former apple employee described
jobs,
his attitude toward work as richmond
spike character assassination in 1985 when
he was tired of hanging out in Siberia
and decided to leave the company that he
had founded and start a brand new one,
or has it been the focus of my entire
adult life was gone and it was devastating
drops out of this experience.
I even thought about running
away from the valley,
but something slowly began to dawn on me.
I still loved what I did and
so I decided to start over.
He started next computer company which
brought its first product to market in
1988.
That can be to the price tag of $10,000
a price way higher than most consumers
were willing to pay.
Needless to say,
it did not sell well.
This wasn't a good style for jobs,
this fledgling company,
and so we decided to shift the
company to building software
with jobs is focused when it was drawn
elsewhere towards something rather
unusual fandom.
And that was the movies.
In 1986,
he bought Pixar from George Lucas as part
of his dream that his company job has
wanted to be responsible for the first
movie done entirely with computer
animation.
It took four years,
but eventually you
achieved that dream well,
that movie,
it was toy story.
It was released in November of 1995 and
it became a favorite film for both kids
and adults.
To this day,
it maintains a perfect one
percent score on rotten tomatoes.
A year after the release of Toy story,
it was even better news jobs took pixar
public and didn't something of a Deja Vu
situation.
His shares were worth $1,000,000,000
after the first day of trading,
the first day of trading,
well,
it was the first thing,
the string of good days for jobs.
Shortly after Pixar winds public,
apple put out the welcoming
mat for Steve Jobs to return.
When he returned to apple in 1997,
the company was operating at
a loss and they needed jobs,
his vision and drive back at the helm.
Apple also announced that they were
struggling next computer company turning a
previous failure of jobs into a success
jobs he triumphantly return to
the company that he had founded.
The company wanted him to bring apple to
the forefront of the personal computer
market.
Within months of his return jobs,
he was named CEO.
He paid himself a salary of one,
$1 a year and didn't exchange,
brought both business acumen and
creative design ideas to the company.
He negotiated a financial deal with
Microsoft that brought apple the cashflow
that it needed to stay afloat while also
helping Microsoft avoid the perception
that they were a monopoly.
Then he envisioned the big
idea that helped bring apple
back to profitability in
its own right,
and that was the Imac.
It was in 1998 that apple released the
brightly colored eggs shape to desktop
computer called the Imac,
and the Imac is even still made today,
although it looks rather different
from the Imac forward applicant jobs,
they just kind to miss.
They revolutionized the way people
listen to music in 2001 with the Ipod,
and then the way they communicated
in 2007 with the iphone,
and then they were pioneers in the
tablet market with the 2010 release.
If the eyepatch job has one set of apple,
we started out to get a computer in
the hands of everyday people and we
succeeded beyond our wildest dreams today.
Well,
it's nearly impossible to walk down the
street without seeing someone with an
apple made device in their hands and
through all these years of professional
success,
jobs still found the time
to focus on his family.
In 1986,
his adoptive mother was diagnosed with
lung cancer and this the first time
prompted jobs.
His interest in his biological parents
when his adoptive mother passed away,
jobs spoke to his father
about contacting his birth.
Parents whose names he had on documents
from his parents' job has minutes,
both his birth mother,
Joanna shy,
bold,
that is biological sister Mona Simpson.
Shortly after his adoptive mother died,
Chicagoland and jobs.
His birth father had divorced in 1962.
When the Syrian migrants opted you
return to Syria after earning his phd,
when jobs was introduced to Mona,
she was still searching for their father.
Jobs joined her in the search
and what they found out,
what it was quite surprising.
The father,
while he was not in Syria,
working in academia rather that father
was living in California and is running a
restaurant.
Incredibly jobs said he had met the man,
are identifying as their father had
even shaken his hands and turned in his
restaurants,
but you'd never known
he was his father jobs,
though he had no interest in getting to
know his father as it goes into the no
his mother and Mona explaining
his decision by saying
it a little bit about him
and they didn't like what I learned.
Well,
I guess it was his birth family jobs also
decided to start a family of his own.
In 1989 jobs,
gave a lecture at Stanford Business School
and he was riveted by a woman in the
front row.
She was right there in the front row in
the lecture hall and I couldn't take my
eyes off her.
I kept losing my train of thought
and started feeling a little giddy.
This is the feeding that jobs described
when he first met Laurene Powell Powell
was an mba students at Stanford and struck
up a conversation with her after the
lecture.
He invited her out to dinner that
night and the two they began.
A romantic relationship is Zen Buddhist
monk presided over the wedding ceremony
at Yosemite National Park in 1991,
and over the next seven years,
the couple had three children.
They remained married until
jobs his death in 2011.
I need to.
All of these successes of the early years
of the 21st century jobs was not free
from worry and well,
neither was apple computers.
In 2003 jobs received the news,
all of us dread.
She had cancer,
his doctors and found a cancerous
tumor in his pancreas and operable.
It was a rare form of cancer,
well jobs.
He refused to listen to his doctors
and to have an operation right away.
Instead,
he opted to explore other options,
namely veganism and acupuncture in
2004 with these alternative methods not
improving his condition.
Job's opted to have the
Cima surgically removed.
Several cancer specialists have since
said that that period of waiting may have
cost jobs,
years of his life in 2005 jobs,
gave a commencement address at Stanford
University that frankly and poignantly
discussed his thoughts on life and death
now that you have to confront them at a
head on the 15 minute speech reflectors
on three moments in his life that helped
him get to where he was in telling those
stories and part of the message the
graduates spans of the world.
To do what you love,
remember you are going to die
and to trust your inner voice.
Remembering that I'll be dead soon
is the most important tool I've ever
encountered to help me make
the big choices in life.
Because almost everything,
all external expectations,
all pride,
all fear of embarrassment or failure.
These things just fall
away in the face of death.
Leaving only what is truly important,
remembering that you were going to die
is the best way I know to avoid the trap
of thinking you have something to lose.
You are already naked.
There is no reason not
to follow your heart.
You closed the speech with simple words
from the 19 seventies counter cultural
magazine,
the whole Earth Catalog.
Stay hungry,
stay foolish.
He commencement address struck
a cord around the world.
It has been viewed over 27 million times
on Youtube and serves as an inspiration
and a stark reminder of
our limited time on earth.
It was a speech that truly every human
can relate to given by a man whose mind
and drive with far more
extraordinary than most humans.
Jobs continue to work it out
or following the surgery,
but in 2008 people began asking
questions about his health.
His appearance began to show his illness.
He was grading and just
didn't seem healthy.
The company continued to explain this
away off the questions were raised.
One tech events,
apple attributed as a parents do a
simple bug and said he was taking
antibiotics.
Shareholders,
they continued to worry and in 2009,
the truth came out,
jobs was suffering from ill health and
ended up having a liver transplant.
Tim Cook,
apple is head of worldwide sales,
filled into CEO while jobs was
recovering from the procedure.
Job's later managed to return to his post
and continue to be involved in the day
to day operations of apple
with his prognosis being
described as excellent bus.
Unfortunately,
this was not to be only a year and a
half after returning to the helm of apple
jobs had to step down as CEO and providing
his reasons to the company bought.
He stated,
I've always said if there ever came a day
when I could no longer meets my duties
and expectations as apple CEO,
I would be the first to let you know.
Unfortunately that day has come though
he stepped down as CEO intended.
Tim Cook the reigns of the company.
Jobs did serve as chairman
of the Apple Board.
Sadly,
it was only for six weeks that he
would work for apple in this capacity.
On the fourth of October,
2011 jobs lost consciousness.
He stayed at home,
surrounded by his family,
died of complications from
his pancreatic cancer.
On October the fifth,
he was only 56 years old.
The Welsh greeted the death of this
technology icon with shock and grief.
California's governor issued
a proclamation for Steve
Jobs Day to be celebrated
and the companies with which
he was associated issued
statements about the life,
creativity,
and innovation of their
founder and partner,
just family held a private funeral,
the details of which are still unknown.
In 56 years of life and 30
years in the tech industry,
Steve Jobs was at the helm of
guiding the world into the future.
He was certainly a
difficult man to deal with,
but he was an innovator,
a businessman and divisionary whose
ideas shaped the world in which we live
today.
So I really hope you enjoyed
that biography of Steve Jobs.
If you did,
please do subscribe to our channel.
We put our brand new
biographies just like this.
Every Monday and every Thursday say,
subscribe for more.
Also,
check out some of our other
biographies over there on the right.
If you like this,
you're probably like those long form.
It's into people's life.
Check them out,
they're a.
they're worth watching loads
more on the channel itself,
and as always,
I'll see you in the next video.